all righty it's time for drew's news
with me at the desk is my trusty
co-pilot rossi ross matthews hi
everybody hi
[Applause]
this is because we now celebrate
something very special on this show
because it's true you know how like on
your social media you'll see like
national french fry day yeah national
cherry pie day exactly national love
your cat day oh i love that there's just
not a day that isn't a reason to
celebrate so every day is a holiday
[Applause]
and today we're actually celebrating
tomorrow's holiday december 17th is
national ugly sweater day hey
we're going to wear our custom sweaters
carob
uglychristmassweater.com they made these
for us they're actually really cute
right
hi
hi hi
look at us
they're very cozy too i love them i have
to say they're really beautifully made
too very soft
nice and and plush unlike they have the
other ones like this look you guys
i can see you in that oh i'm taking this
one yeah and what about this one you
guys anyone like baby yellow
well i just we look so cute in our our
ugly holidays i know i wish everybody
could like join in with i know well
well guess what
you're all getting a 100 gift card to
ugly christmas sweaters.com
[Applause]
experiment get into it i love a
collective experience so thank you to
this company for giving us the chance to
bond this way i really do appreciate it
okay so remember i said i sort of woke
up on the emotional side of the bed
today and i saw this
on the news
and i just want to show you
this thing so there was like this camel
that they had hired
to build a nativity scene in kansas
and for some reason this camel just
decided you know what
i'm out of here
and so this camel's just running through
the highway and it's just like
i don't know what this camel
was doing but this camel
gave me life thank you camel thank you
turning around my morning thank you i
just took a running camel
that's all it took
all right well from running camel to kim
kardashian
there's no other transition to make
kim kardashian just revealed it's a
magical christmas morning in her
household all month long listen to this
you guys the daily mail reports that
every day in december kim k wakes her
kids up to the sound of a live christmas
carol on the baby grand yep she shared
this clip of grammy winning producer
phil cornish playing a holiday medley
that's in her living room she has a live
piano player wake up kids and that
family is very festive can i just can i
name drop for just a second uh yeah okay
so remember i was on e for years and
years and years covering all the red
carpets and the so i would get invited
to the kardashian christmas party which
apparently is like the biggest deal ever
i have been in a buffet line with j.lo
what did she eat yeah i was trying to
eye it was last salad i was in um i was
behind kanye once he got ham yeah ham
yeah um i know it was really cool though
for some because it was like one of
these things it's not like the other i
did not belong so i just was like on
safari essentially you know what i mean
with like celebrities everywhere i was
observing their every move rossi any
place you don't belong i don't want to
be preach girl yes
very cool well next up the incredible
alicia keys another just extraordinary
game changer just shared something
fascinating about the start of her
relationship with her husband swizz
beatz the atlanta black star reports
that it was not love at first sight in
fact alicia admits that at first swizz
gave her the ick but then she spent more
and more time with him
and she came to realize that she didn't
know him at all in the beginning and
that she was just reacting to a first
impression
i love this
ross thoughts
if you give me the egg girl i'm gonna
stick with the ick i am not evolved
enough to get around changing your mind
well there hasn't been i i haven't
i mean i like for wellington for example
the first time i saw him my fiance i was
like that one you know i hello hello at
first sight it was a love at first sight
so i don't know if someone wrote me the
wrong way if i could get i don't know
well i can prove um
that
this can happen because when i first met
my kid's dad will
um we
went on a few dates and we were just not
a match like we just did not have that
chemistry and two and a half years later
we ran into each other and the second we
saw each other
it was like
our lives changed so i'm actually really
glad that she's out there telling that
story because i wanted to instill a
little bit of patience
in our society when we're doing this and
it's like i don't even like his face
move on what
yeah hold on
do you even know that person
you might
miss out on one of the most important
chapters of your life mm-hmm i love that
drew you know what i think it just
changed my mind yeah i think and that
rarely happens at the desk i'll just say
but yeah i think you're right i i
there's something about the right person
but it's also the right time you have to
be ready to accept people for who they
are and learn take the time to learn and
all those first impressions that you
were so convinced of might have a very
different meaning once you really get to
know that person
so
don't close yourself off right away
[Music]
you